IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S HASHTAG
WAR.
>> IN HONOR OF ELTON JOHN,
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS OLDER
MUSICIANS.
SO
TED OLDGENT
AGE AGAINST THE MACHINE.
YOU CAN PLAY ALONG AT HOME BY
TWEETING YOUR #OLDER MUSICIANS
TO @MIDNIGHT.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK.
>> SHERLE CLOAEE FEET.
>> YES, POINTS.
>> THE WHO'S THAT NOW?
>> POINTS!
DEFINITELY POINTS.
SPADE?
>> TED NOT-SO-NUGENT.
>> POINTS.
>> CHANGED A LITTLE BIT.
>> I HAVE ANOTHER ONE.
I'M NOT DONE.
>> FAN FOLDS 105.
>> FINE, FINE.
NEAL BRENNAN?
>> MARVIN GAY MARRIAGE OPPONENT.
>> OH, I LIKE THAT.
YOU TOOK A POLITICAL POINT.
WELL DONE.
ANDI OSHO.
>> ALICIA, WHERE'S MY KEYS.
>> YOUNG PEOPLE LOSE THEIR KEYS,
TOO, BUT I'LL GIVE THAT TO YOU.
>> DAVID SLOWEY.
>> POINTS!
>> DON'T BOO ME.
SPADE?
>> TOUCHED BY AN ANGEL FISH.
GIVING IT ONE MORE CHANCE.
>> I LIKE THE CALLBACK.
I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT.
ANDI OSHO?
>> RAY PARKINSON.